أعتقد أن هناك ثلاثة ، إنها اقتراح
يربح يربح ويخسر
أه نحن فزنا يمكننا التحدث
عن لماذا
وكيف ربح الإماراتيون لماذا وكيف ومن الواضح
أن الإسرائيليين
أه الخاسر في كل هذا واضح هو
الحركة الوطنية الفلسطينية
التي  الذين تم تهميشهم
وتجاهلهم فعليًا ، حيث
بدأت الدول العربية في التفكير في
التطبيع مع إسرائيل دون
إحراز تقدم كبير في عملية السلام الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية ،
حسنًا ، دعونا نتحدث عن الخاسر
هنا ،
فأين يترك هذا للفلسطينيين
ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبة للفلسطينيين
ذاهبون؟  إلى الأمام ،
أعني أعتقد أنه من الواضح أنهم
يظلون
أضعف حزب منقسمة خياراتهم هي
قاتمة للغاية
الكفاح العسكري الكفاح المسلح ليس
خيارًا ، فالتفاوض بموجب الشروط
التي قدمتها الإدارة الرابحة من
قبل حكومة إسرائيل
ليس خيارًا وهناك  مقياس جيد
للانجراف
محمود عباس رئيس
السلطة الفلسطينية
فقد مصداقيته شعبيته
تتراجع
حماس رم.  عيني معزولة ومحاصرة من قبل الإسرائيليين
ويبدو لي أننا عالقون
في فضاء بين
حل الدولتين وهو أمر مهم للغاية للتخلي
عنه من ناحية
ولكن من الصعب جدًا تنفيذه من ناحية
أخرى وأنا خائف
أه بدرجات متفاوتة من الاختلال الوظيفي
والعنف وربما فترات الهدوء
حيث سنبقى لبعض
الوقت ، تقول إن الإمارات العربية المتحدة هي الفائز هنا
ولكن من المحتمل أن تكون إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة قد
تفوقت على الاتحاد
الأوروبي والإمارات العربية المتحدة هنا أعني هذا هو  انتصار كبير
بالنسبة لهم ولكن فقط من أجل
الوعد بالعودة
بشكل جيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أنت تعرف أن الدليل
الواضح
موجود في الحلوى التي يضرب بها المثل إذا
تم تعليق الضم في الواقع
، يمكن لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة أن تدعي بحق
أنها كانت نوعًا من المخلصين
من الاثنين  - حل الدولة أه ومؤيد
لصالح القضية الفلسطينية
وتذكر
أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة تقرأ استطلاعات الرأي في واشنطن
أيضًا وهم يرون أن ثروة دونالد ترامب
تتدهور لذا فهم يتحوطون في رهاناتهم وقد
حصلوا على شهرة في  الإدارة الرابحة من
خلال هذه الخطوة
من ناحية وقد وضعوا
أنفسهم يجب أن يصبح جو بايدن
رئيسًا
ليكون شريكًا مهمًا جدًا ومن
المحتمل أن يكون
مهمًا لإدارته ،
فهم يحاولون فصل أنفسهم
عن السعوديين الذين سمعتهم في
واشنطن على الأقل في
إدارة بايدن  ستكون فقيرة جدًا ، ومثل
العديد من الدول العربية بدءًا من السادات
، فهم يفهمون أن الطريق إلى
واشنطن يمر عبر
القدس حيث ترى
الدول الأخرى بعد هذا الأمر الذي
يحتمل أن يكون
جيدًا ، أعتقد أن هذا هو أنك طرحت
سؤالًا بالغ الأهمية أقصده
هناك  هي حفنة من الاحتمالات
وهي احتمالات أستبعدها وأعتقد أن هناك احتمالًا حقيقيًا بأن
العمانيين
على الرغم من أن الكابوز لم يعد
رئيسًا للدولة وقد يستغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت حتى يتمكنوا من تعديل
يوماني ليصبح
أمرًا ممكنًا  أه خليفة
التطبيع يفعله البحرينيون
برضوخ السعوديين
الجائزة الكبرى  بالطبع هي المملكة العربية السعودية
،
ولا أعتقد أن هناك أي طريقة للمراهنة
على وجه اليقين
بأن السعوديين سيتبعون في أي وقت قريبًا ،
لا يزال لدى محمد بن سلمان مساحة صغيرة جدًا للمناورة
نظرًا لمكانة المملكة العربية السعودية في
العالم العربي
والقيود التقليدية التي تحتها
السعوديون يعملون على القضية الفلسطينية ،
لذلك
إذا حصلت على قوة جذب إذا حصلت على
البحرينيين والعمانيين وربما حتى أدوات تناول الطعام
على الرغم من
أن هذا وضع أكثر تعقيدًا ،
فسوف ينتهي بك الأمر مع
وزن ثقيل جدًا
فيما يتعلق بالتطبيع مع
الإسرائيليون الذين سيعززون
الرسالة إلى الفلسطينيين
أم أن مجالاتهم وشكوكهم
في هجر
العرب قد ثبت أنها حقيقية جدًا آرون
ديفيد ميلر ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك دائمًا
للحصول على وجهة نظرك ،
شكرًا جزيلاً روبن يعتني بك أيضًا